Let's wrap up this lesson by looking at adding and subtracting complex numbers.
Any number that is the sum of a real number and an imaginary number is an
example of a complex number. Complex numbers are in the form a plus bi or a
minus bi. A and b are any real numbers and the second term is an imaginary
number. It's imaginary because it has i or the square root of negative 1.
Instead of writing the square root of negative 1 all the time, we usually just
write i. So if we want to add or subtract any complex numbers together, we
treat i just like a radical. We can combine any terms that both contain an i,
since they both have a square root of negative 1. So what do you think these
would be. If we added this complex number to this complex number, what would be
the answer? And if we subtracted this complex number from this one, what would
be the result? Keep in mind that you really need to just combine like terms.
You're also need to remember what to do when subtracting a quantity. Good luck
on this one.